Father's Day is coming up a little bad
joke
what did the janitor say when he jumped
out of the closet
[Music]
why
I like that one
all right here we are it's Father's Day
we're both fathers yes we've been given
some dad jokes to read we don't know the
content of these no cards so we're gonna
we're gonna hear it now uh a man I'm
very nervous a man walks into a seafood
restaurant and asks for a lobster tail
the waitress smiled sweetly and said
once upon a time there was a handsome
Lobster
[Laughter]
I lost your tail a tale about lobsters
three years ago my doctor told me I was
deaf I haven't heard from him since
thank you
what do you call a fish wearing a bow
tie
sophisticated not bad that's not a
terrible joke really
how do you console an English teacher
there there
laughs
it's there three ways and I appreciate
it and I actually hate it when people
confuse them why do fathers take an
extra pair of socks when they go golfing
in case they get a hole in one
of them
here's the joke ready my co-workers
laugh at my jokes in in-person meetings
but never in online
meetings when asked then why they said
that my jokes weren't remotely funny
you know the pun is is all the lowest
form of humor possibly some say and this
is a play on words remotely meaning in
this case two two things you know I do
this professionally you know I'm not a
Canadian but I mean I I do say funny
lines so I think my rendering of that
was as good as I could have done it
remotely maybe I hit the remotely too
much but anyway that's my that's my
that's my adventure there you go
dad joke number one
I asked my phone Siri why am I so bad
with women and she said I'm Alexa you
good decent but I feel like
how do computers get drunk they take
screenshots
that's very I'm gonna hold on to that
one dad joke number three
I asked my dog what's two minus two
he said nothing
okay that got a good dad joke reaction
what do you call a factory that makes
okay products a satisfactory
expensive have you seen chimneys they're
through the roots
[Music]
oh my God
my mom was a radiologist she met my dad
when he came in for an x-ray I wonder
what she saw in him
I wonder what she saw in him yeah yeah
bones
you know
phones and maybe some
metal screws and plates if he was in the
war
[Applause]
that concludes our daddy Happy Father's
Day you can tell some better jokes out
there dads Happy Father's Day everybody
I hope you enjoy Happy Father's Day
fellas Happy Father's Day great
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]